With Ken told 12,
from 10 to 12,
who can to 16.
We are still in what is
known the middle ground,
which is a moral ground.
The middle ground of, uh,
uh, in hell. Uh,
we are between the area of
incontinence that we saw,
uh,
in the last few weeks and the area
of malice when this middle ground,
which is the ground of violence
or beastiality as it, uh,
as it is also called a,
what I want to draw your attention to
first of all is the fact that Dante is a
presiding symbols.
The presiding figures in this area,
uh,
all figures hybrid figures,
figures of Doubleness,
uh, the minor tor and the
centaurs and Canto 12.
You have the Harpies, uh, you know,
this filthy file figures,
monsters with the face
of, uh, of, of, uh, women,
uh, devouring, uh, all
the foliage in the trees,
the trees, cantor 13, uh,
and then, uh, uh, Chris,
we'll go on with, uh, uh,
other emblems of again,
monsters and the figure of, uh, uh,
but that's the figure of fraud.
I don't want to get into that.
Figures of also again, monitors
and centers in, uh, 15.
What is the, what is the importance
of this figures in, they are,
they are neoplatonic images,
figures of centaurs minor tours,
uh,
understood to signify the
doubleness of human beings,
the capacity of human beings
to join within themselves,
both the human and the beast,
steel or animal,
the animal, uh, experiences,
possibilities of being,
uh,
in neoplatonic thinking,
especially in the 12th century says to
give her a historical ring to what we are
saying that 12th century,
the so called shark fins and more so
in the 15th century Florence with Pico,
uh, the figures, the, the, the
whole idea is that human beings are,
uh,
really kind of copular or
neutral entities capable of,
we have the potential of
this doubleness within them.
They're capable of becoming fully
rational or descending into beastiality.
And their position in the
ladder of being is one of, uh,
Arthur indeterminacy in the 12th century.
This is not the case.
They still believe in this.
Images are fixed,
images of Ed pities creatures capable of
being at the same time expressing this
dual impulses are the beast
deal and the human impulse.
This is Dante,
seems to be quite aware that somehow,
uh, the, the symbols do not
completely characterize,
uh,
what human beings really are.
That the ability of human beings to redeem
themselves to free themselves are of
a certain state or a four
plunge into the opposite state.
So there's a difference between the
symbols and what human beings are going to
be able to do. This is the,
this is really the, the, the,
the reason why I focused on Canto on
Canto ask you to read Canto to 12 where
Dante places tyrants. It's an an,
it's really an anonymous can't, well,
there are no great figures, no
great personalities. And we do know,
and Dante give us a list of all the
tyrants of his time and the chirons that
ionizers of Syracuse
Alexander, uh, the, the SLA,
no of his own, his own time
in Padua, uh, et cetera.
Uh, they are the features of a
tyranny, but at the same time,
he places next to them,
figures of educators,
figures of teachers, uh, such
as, for instance, Kyron. Uh,
and, and, and this is a little
bit ironic because he says,
come straight after Dante's exemplary
representation of Virgil's own teaching in
canned to 11. You remember when, uh,
virtual goes on explaining in
great detail the shape of, uh, of,
of inferno, he here. Now, once again,
Dante takes the other perspective
that which it takes to be the tyranny.
The tyranny of teaching,
they say as sort of teaching
does not allow that freedom.
That the very symbols,
the very presiding, uh,
figures of this canto also seem to,
to deny they are there forever,
man and beast.
And Dante claims clearly that there is a
teaching that has to allow the soul to,
of have the freedom to move either in
the direction of rationality or the
freedom of the choice to move in it's
opposite direction. So, uh, this is, uh,
the substance I think of Canto are 12.
We come though to kind to 13,
which is, uh, one of the most
remarkable cantos of in fairness,
it's the cant of the suicides and
Danton counters here. A figure,
a poet,
very well known poet,
very well known figure
of maybe, uh, the late,
um,
the middle part with the 13th
century called Pierre the Levenia.
And as you can,
as you read through the Kanto,
you will see that he punts on both
terms of the name Pierre Peter and he,
he thinks of himself as a figure of Peta.
One Who holds the keys, the two keys
of the kingdom, the keys of power,
but also the last name peer,
the Levenia meaning of the vineyard.
And this is verse,
this is,
we are going to witness now and
metamorphosis of a human being.
Then metamorphosis is a human being from
being human to becoming a vegetable at
plant. Uh, this is, uh, the
story of suicides and we shall,
we shall see what Dante things
about suicides. One, he,
why does he thinks is such,
such an evil as to become them in this
area of violence against the self.
You do know her, Dante, I
don't have to go over this,
but you do know that Dante distinguishes
violence against self violence against
others as in Canto 12,
uh,
violence against nature and violence
even against the divinity and can talk in
Canto 14. Let's look at canto
13, a little bit of a, some,
some textual details and then,
uh, and then we'll, we'll,
we'll discuss, uh, some of
the issues of the Canto. Um,
Nessus had not yet reached the other side.
Again,
when we set out through a wood which
was not marked by any path here,
there seems to be no directions at all.
Almost as if Dante we're revisiting,
came to one of inferno,
the same idea of, uh, uh,
a sense of loss of self and adumbrating
what suicide may also be at some,
at, at, at, at some level,
a loss of a loss of some
idea of one's own being,
some idea of what one is or should be.
We are not told anything more.
But then rather than shifts to the
description of the natural landscape,
the world of nature, the
landscape, and you, uh, uh,
if as you read,
you must be struck by how he's
highlighting a peculiar style.
And I want to emphasize this style,
this figurations of style and no green
leaves but of Dusky Hugh series of
antithesis, first of all, a series
of antithesis but also an APP for us.
Negatives,
no smooth bowels but not
that and worked antithetical,
but at the same time, repetition of
this. No. And therefore foric no, no,
no fruits where there,
but most of the storms,
no breaks or harsh.
And then that the savage beast hate
the tilde lands between the Cessna and
called NATO. We are in what? In in a,
in a place in the landscape where
this is the style called, uh, uh,
there's a technical term
for the Dan to deploy.
It's called [inaudible], which
simply means a privation emphasizing.
There's nothing positive here,
but it's a way of subtracting from what
is missing rather than what is there
that is really a negation, the style of
integration. Uh, but at the same time,
so the antithesis making us think about
how the world might be no green leaves
but of Dusky Hue say
this is a style of uh,
taking away and they gave taking
it away from any substantial, uh,
description of the landscape,
no breaks or harsh and then
etc. Here make their nests.
The loathsome harpies again,
a hybrid figures just as we had the,
the same tour in the previous Canto,
um,
from the strawberries with this
more presage of future eels,
they have white wings and human next and
phases feed Claude and the great valis
feathered and they make lamentations
on the strange trees. Uh,
so we are in the world.
Are we really at world of
negation a world of, uh, uh,
monstrosities and a
world of, uh, probation,
um, what is happening to human beings
here? That's, that's really the, the,
the question that he seems to be racing,
but let me just proceed
even more care here.
The whole scene recasts an important
scene in book three of the Aeneid.
This is indeed also a major confrontation
between Dante whole can't dramatizes a
major confrontation
between Dante and Virgil,
the author of the Aeneid about some of
these issues. Where is the metamorphosis?
Where is nature? What is the place
of human beings within nature?
Because Dante and Virgil things
in a sharply different ways for,
um, the metamorphosis versus the
scene that Nancy here is recalling,
um,
is the scene of book three of the Aeneid
where Pori Doris at causing the veneers
has been killed.
And he's,
you remember that is the speaking trees
in there to nes arrives in Trisha,
which is Asia Minor.
He thinks that his dad is the place
which the gods of assigned to him and he
does that which she feels has that which
he knows has to be done wherever and
whenever you want to build a city,
consecrate the ground,
how the ground by building an altar and
by purifying the ground through fire as
he tries to do this.
The altars horror is at the center in
the Aeneid at the center of the human
community.
He's pulling his plucking Eh,
a a bow and he hears a voice
and we still his, his, his, uh,
his shutters is scared and the
voice comes, it's poly Doris,
his cousin who,
who tells the story that has been
killed because of the sacrilegious,
I mean combated wherever.
Consecration virtual once one has to
believe to think of cannot be really
carried out because of the sacrilege has
been that of the killing of Pomodoros
on account of the, the, the,
the goal that he carried,
that they wanted to prompt him
or they want to rob him off.
Um, so, and, and, and knee
as he is a voice. Why do you,
uh,
whether do you pull me out of this and
put a daughter simply asks that a proper
burial be given to him so that he can
descend peacefully into hades and he has
complies and leaves that place in the
knowledge that is not the place I signed
to him.
Sacrilege was such that he cannot really
quite found the city on the place of a
crime,
such an atrocious crime.
Dante's revisiting that particular scene.
In fact,
I repeat 10 to 13,
the recast that scene and it's a major
encounter with Virgil and Virgil's hole
pattern, whole system of values. And
let's see how this is going to continue.
So we have the background
with uh, uh, some, some, uh,
stylistics of negativity,
the styles of an allegation as if suicide,
where this fundamental
sacrilege, uh, that denies the,
the, the, some, some, some, some
reality that we don't know yet.
And the good master began to speak to me.
So Virgil intervene,
um,
minding us, reminding us that this
is in the book, three of the Aeneid,
which by the way,
and other little detail book,
three of their need is the book of the
veneer that Dante Joe's from the most.
And if some of you want to write a paper
on how many scenes and why you should
go and, uh, go ahead and write that
kind of paper. One reason is the book,
three of their need is the,
is the book of Nes Exile,
the homelessness of Nes. Nes. We
still nowhere, he's just uh, uh,
has just left the, the uh,
Troy he's going to, about to,
about to leave Carthage Dido's
home and about to get to into,
into Sicily but never really quite
been able to say this is really where I
belong.
This is really the praise one.
One can call home whatever
that may be for him.
The good master began to speak to me
virtual interrupts before the go further,
farther,
no,
that we're in the second round and
she'll be until they come to the horrible
sand look,
well therefore and Asha see things that
would discredit my telling of them.
This is a hyperbole on
the part of virtual.
You're going to see what I have
been describing in a sense.
This is the reason why I'm the all the
the and authority and why I'm guiding
through you through this because I have
seen imaginatively at least I have seen
some of the things that you are
experiencing and what you will see.
The reality of it all will exceed my,
uh,
my own abilities to tell of it.
It stands of humility on
the part of the teacher.
Then afforded a mild correction of the
claims about teaching and cantor 12,
he said, this is one theme that seems
to be running through. And then, uh, uh,
Dante continuous are heard from
every side wheelings poured forth.
And so none that made them
so that, Oh, bewildered,
I stopped. And now another conceit
that we should come back to.
I think he thought, I thought, oh,
it's clearly,
um,
we call it an amplification one
at a way of playing with one verb,
but also inferring what the
thought of the other would be.
Uh,
it's a descent into a kind of,
into the boundaries of one's own mind,
a way in which Dante dramatizes the fact
that there is no real conversation now
going on between him and Virgil.
It's,
it's a way of descending into
the, uh, what I call exactly the,
the, the, the loneliness of, uh,
of Dante's own thoughts, I think.
And then reiterated once again and
a, for Rick, I think he thought,
I thought more of this later,
that all divorces among the trucks
came from people were hiding from us.
So the master said,
if the break of annual branch
from one of these trees,
all the present tolls will prove mistaken.
Then I put up my hand a little and proctor
twig from a great stone and its trunk
cried and this is in year
three lines 39 and following.
That's the way book through third
of three of the knee begins.
Why the start telling me and
we had turned dark with blood.
It began again. Why mangles
Tommy has done no spirit of pity.
We were men and now our turn to stocks,
the hand might well have been more
pitiful. We've been souls of serpents.
It's a green brand.
There is burning at one end,
drips from the other and
hisses with escaping wind.
So from the broken splinter came forth
words and blood together at which I left
for the tip and still this one
afraid and virtual intervenes.
If he could have believed
before wounded soul,
what it had never seen,
but in my lines in my need,
he would not have stretched forth his
hand against him. My sage replied,
but they think being incredible
made me prompt him to the deed,
which grieves myself.
But tell me who that was so that for some
amens he may revive their fame in the
world above what he is
permitted to return.
The irony of reviving the fame in a
place where there is no possibility of
revival,
a,
there is no possibility of coming back
to life and they wear their natural world
is not capable of behaving naturally.
Where,
where there is no real growth, no real
change here. It's always going to be,
it's the most unnatural of
places. Uh, saw the shadow of,
of this unnatural ness is
going to be cast over the, uh,
the scene with the encounter with Brunetto
Latini. What is this, this idea here?
Uh, in a sense, this is already the
confrontational between Virgil and Dante.
If he could have believed that
which had described it is this,
Dante wants to test the truth value
of what he had read in the Aeneid.
He had read the scene at the end.
[inaudible],
let me see how this is and finds out
that that which he sees is entirely
different from Virgil's account.
Uh, in a way we are really,
really drawing our attention to
what we call the act of reading.
How do we read or what do we believe?
When we read the story and we read
a story, we yield in many ways too.
So it's part,
we want the,
the story that we read to read
us as much as we want to read it,
we want the story to,
to explain us to ourselves,
to hold a mirror up to
us to see the who we are.
But Dante is literally also
implying the need to violate the,
the,
the letter of the Aeneid is I,
he had to do because whatever he had,
any virtual had described,
exceeded a believability.
It was just an incredible account
and he has to test the reality of,
of that scene.
So that's,
that's really the part of the
confrontation between the two.
And now let's see what he hears.
And the trunk said,
thou swear Lewis me with a gentle
speeches where we call Cup Tatsuo.
I won't have to write it on the, on
the, on here, on the board, the cap tax,
your benevolence.
Yeah.
You know that whenever a
great rhetorical trick,
uh,
whenever you give a speech or whatever,
people speak to you in public,
especially of our privately, they, uh,
willing engage in this way of
capturing your benevolence,
about telling a story, playing with
something about their modesty or whatever.
Now you saw Louis May
so fascinated. So I, uh,
the lower of your rhetorical
language or your rhetorical powers,
we are dealing with rhetoric first of
all with style and now then with the
language of the text and now with the
language of the exchange. So this is it.
It is as if, uh, uh, the,
the suicide has a lot to do with this
trait of language is characteristic of
language that so Louis me with a gentle
speech that I cannot be silent and let
it not burden youth from
beguiled into talk for a little.
I am he that help both.
The keys here is the pun on Peter.
It's as if he were Saint Peter holds the
two keys of the Kingdom of Fredrick's
heart. Uh, and now the,
you can see that all the language of
believing faith that has been going around
in the previous lines of the candle seem
to be gravitating around the figure of
Frederick.
They cane who is a kind of,
let's call them the god of the
city, right? Uh, because his name,
that's what it means in Italian.
The specialists,
it's not an English who say Frederick,
it has a feather Ricoh,
which really repeats the idea
of, uh, of, of faith within it,
as if all faith all believes really
have to converge and go toward this.
Uh, this, this, uh,
emperor of Sicily, the,
he's a hunch fun.
He's a famous German king,
a ruling over Sicily and,
and,
and living there was the chancellor
of the empire and also the founder,
by the way, let me say something
more about him. He's the founder.
He's the one who conceived
the first university,
the first State University in Europe,
the University of Naples,
because Frederick wanted a university
that would prepare lawyers,
diplomats, uh, people would go
on state missions who can write,
uh, uh, uh, papers for the state,
and they would not be at all,
or one of the schools that they
were universities where, uh,
under the aegis of, for instance,
the canon lawyers that theologians,
so this was, say the first La Secular
School in Europe was an imperial.
CNN are like, for instance,
the University of Paris, uh,
which was under the symbol painters in
the domain of both the bishop of Paris
and the King of France. And hence a
lot of, uh, conflicts between, uh,
between the two. Uh, uh,
so he's a chancellor,
he's the founder and of of the university.
He was a poet.
And he also compiled the so
called institutes of justice
for the kingdom where,
which is all, uh, inspire. The
institutes are all inspired by, uh,
the language of moderation, the
language of, uh, of, of, uh, uh,
idealistic language of older,
uh,
and the natural law that could follow,
could they could organize the state.
And clearly, uh, the
reality is that by his act,
uh,
peer delivery in your shows that there's
no such a thing called that he doesn't
really believe in what he claims to be
the principal of the legal organization
of, of the state, which is, uh,
uh, natural law. I have been.
So I have bought the keys of Fredericks
heart and turn them locking and
unlocking so softly that I kept nearly
every other main from his secrets.
He is the secretary of the
emperor word as you know,
secretary.
Uh,
which becomes very crucial throughout
the renaissance is a counselor,
but the secretary means comes,
it's a word that comes from the Latin,
from to secrete it. This is a fake.
It's a, here's the figure who distills.
That's the creating distills, the, the,
that which the emperor keeps
hidden in his heart. Oh, he's,
he has this power of distillation
and knowing us and through this,
this selection,
what has to be shared and what
has to be kept concealed from all,
all others. Okay. So pipe,
the figure of a prestige.
He views himself as a,
as a strict,
and he was collaborator of the emperor
and that brought again such faithfulness.
Now that question of fidelity in the way
we read the text in the way we believe,
what we read is brought into,
it's sort of rephrase refracted into
the language of Fidel Loyalty as
faithfulness to the emperor,
to the growers office that are
lost for its sleep and strength.
The causes of the suicide,
the causes of his tragic of appeared.
The Levinas tragic downfall.
I want to be at the Harlot,
personification for envy. Envy. Uh,
the,
the sin there is product
that Aquinas for instance,
views as the worst possible sin. Yeah. Uh,
because it is really very close to hatred
and close to hatred in the sense that
it has nothing.
All sins have some positivity to it,
and all you are, you're a glutton
is because that piece of cake,
there's something about it that
no lures show to you are you have,
have this jar proud.
It's because you really have some sense
of your excellence or some which is the
real sin.
Contempt for others.
Believe that others are not as good
as you as you would think you are.
So it's not so much that you look at
yourself stretching the hand toward the
divinity, the pride of Lucifer,
right? They're real sin is that you,
you kick around those who
you perceive are below.
You all since have some kind of
positive they except for one.
And that's envy.
Envy only likes nothing.
It's not jealousy. You know, you do
have the kind of story, all of you,
I'm sure our readers of Othello,
right?
Because that's really a confrontation
with an envy and jealousy.
That is the envy. Uh, how
Jen Othello, maybe jealous,
but the one who is really envious is Jago
one once he doesn't want this demo of
himself, he can't stand the idea that
the other guy's happy. That's envy.
Jealousy is the fear of
losing jealous is almost, uh,
an ingredient of love. Andreas
Capilano says she really are in love.
It must be some rational
aspect too of jealousy in it.
But here, uh, the, the cause
of, of uh, uh, the court,
the court, which is always
that little microcosm, right?
Uh,
even for Dante writes a treatise on
language or the theorists of law about,
about the function of language in the
court because the court is the place of
laws is the praise of poetry
is the place of a, uh,
political persuasion.
These are the,
the various dimensions of
the powers of language.
And then you do know about the
court from Andreas Capilano's.
That's another topic for you to explore
Dante's figuration of the court and from
all possible, uh, uh, points
of view here. Dante views.
Now the court is micro
cause of a political oda and
idealism as being literally
poisoned by the presence of a
contaminated by the presence of envy,
the Harlot.
And that never turned a shameless eyes.
And You understand that metaphor. It's
not so much that it belongs to the Harlot.
The fact is that the
word envy as you know,
is a word that are in Italian
or in English, in videos.
It's Nvidia,
which is at the monetized as non video.
So it's whole,
it's an idea. It's a kind of
blindness to the world outside.
And here Dante's panelists turn the
shameless eyes. We seem to be, uh,
in a sort of representation of the harlot,
this and the seduction of the holiday.
But it's also also plays on this, uh,
on this notion of what MV really means
and common bane and the vice of codes and
now inflamed all mines against me.
Look how the language
now sort of takes over.
It takes over and Dante
is just playing with and,
and multiplying these terms,
the same terms repeated over and
over again and those inflamed.
So inflame the dusters.
The name for the Emperor Caesar that
happy owners turn to this bull was,
this is the formula for the, the, the,
the formulaic definition of tragedy that
he's giving happy owners turn to this
more walls.
We have the Lavigna is aware
of his own tragic Destinee,
his own tragic downfall and,
and seals his fate as a tragic fate.
And now my mind in scornful
temper thinking by dying
to escape from score made
me just unjust to myself at once again,
the style of repetitions and a foric peer.
The lavigna constitutes himself
into a closed circuit and,
and the doubling of
language reflect the self.
And let me just go on and tell you
what I think is, is going on here.
When you read the sentence and I'm
dying to skip from sort of made me just
unjust to myself.
And the obvious question that I think
you should really ask and if I gave you a
chance to ask, you would ask
how many cells are there in him?
Made me just unjust to myself.
How many,
how many persons are there, how many
fingers are there in one, in, in,
in pure the Livy?
Yeah.
The text that best glosses the scene.
It's tragic occurrence here.
Appears in the city of
God of the Augustan book,
one where Augustan is telling the
story of Rome and the death of,
and the end of the period of the
monarchy, you know, the seven kings,
right? Their stores. And with the
s the story of the seven, the, the,
the expulsion of the tar. Quinn's, the,
the last king is attributed to the
fact that the famous matron of Rome,
but the name of Lucretia come down too,
by the way,
mentions in limbo though he's,
he has a lot of ideas about who or what,
what,
what is the guilt of a suicide.
We shall see that a great figure
from an antiquity, Cato, uh,
as suicide will appear and will inaugurate
the proctorial canticle in can't hold
one. So that is always making some crucial
discriminations, crucial distinctions.
At any rate. They are the story
that Lucre that Augustine, uh,
tells in book. One of the, of the
city of God is that of uh, uh,
the rape of Lucretia,
the rape of Lucretia and Augustan is
fierce about the fact that she commits
suicide.
How that she then she commit suicide
are of the guilt and shame that she had
been violated.
It rape by the,
by, by, by realtors. And she says,
how the shit there to take her own life.
Because here is the chase through Cretia
who is embarrassed of the unchaste
Lucretia.
This is a sin of false transcendence.
The belief that I can
be not completely cold.
I do not coincide fully with who I
am so that I have to double myself,
have to see myself as different
from what, uh, what I am.
I can do justice against
myself by doing this.
For Dante are going to dentist texts.
This doubling of peer,
the Ravinia is a saint
of false transcendence.
The way the suicide is praying God to
oneself and this punishing oneself for
wrongs that he,
the suicide perceives Lucretia.
She that perceived as have fouling
how reality and see what I mean?
This is the kind of, uh, uh,
there's a kind of, um, some, uh,
kind of doubleness that seems to be
running through and Dante's rendering
through this idea of a start by the new
roads. So the street, I swear to you,
never did I break faith with my Lord who
is so worthy of honor and the father of
your return to the world.
Let him establish my memory.
Still lies under the blow
that, uh, Envi, uh, gave it.
So, uh, the story of appear. The
Livinia exemplifies the story of,
of dramatizes, the story
of the tragic, uh, uh,
experience of suicide.
And Dante here gives of suicide in
exactly theological and Augustinian,
uh, account. He views it,
looks at it from an Augustinian our
point of view. We skipped Canto,
uh,
14,
and we go now to another memorable
candidate and memorable or can't 15,
uh, memorable, um, uh,
encounter with a dentist,
teacher Brunetto Latini,
um,
who was probably 50 years.
He senior who was a translator at,
who adapted in the vernacular,
a Cicero's rhetorical works, who was, uh,
also who's a teacher of the
Florentines, a teacher of Dante. Um,
and who,
uh,
who really stands for the great values
of the rhetorical humanistic or she's
Heronian tradition. Uh, the idea of a,
he opposed the idea of the
Republic of Florence. Uh,
he said wealth because he does not want
you do know that they give billions are
those who are in favor of the
imperial control of the state.
And for him to be a wealth is really
to claim that he's on the side of the
republic, that he wants the
throat and the republic. Um,
he was sent to an embassy, uh,
he went to Toledo by the way,
which at the time was the
center of a great translations.
And He may have brought from Toledo
translations or of Dante new,
uh,
such as perhaps the account of the
Mohammed's vision and be assent to,
to, uh, to paradise.
That's really a very doubtful a question,
but it's,
it circulates increasingly
within a Dante Dante studies,
the perimeter of Dante
Studies. Uh, and, and,
and Burrito what he was going
on an embassy to friends,
um, was banned from, he
eventually returned to Florence.
Uh,
but he said figure that that Dante
really tries to pattern himself after
effectively. It's, it's uh, uh,
the teaching of Brunetto is what guides
him at least in the initial phase of his
political concerns that other experiences,
intellectual experiences that
we'll intervene and we'll
change radically Dante's
thinking.
Uh,
what I'm trying to do in these classes
is also to give you a sense of the shifts
in, in his perceptions and his
understanding of the world.
I will be telling you at some point
that, uh, there were, there were, uh,
extraordinary encounters
that he had with uh,
some theologians in some,
some philosophers within Florence that
gave him a completely different view from
the one that [inaudible] instilled in him.
So let's see what happens between the
toilet. We are in the area. Once again,
violence, this time, violence,
it is nature and that is
[inaudible] is damned,
is condemned for a sin of Sodom.
There is no evidence at all from
any other sources that that's what,
that's where he was. And, and,
and I have to tell you that Dante also
has a different understanding of Solomon
when he comes to pull gatory.
Um, for instance, Canto 26,
uh, where the, the sodomites are in,
in the process of redeeming,
of seeking some kind of redemption
and cleansing. But Anyway,
this is the candle here. Let's
see how he proceeds. Now,
one of the hard margins bears us on and
the vapor from the stream makes a shade
above such shelters,
the water and the banks from the fire.
Uh, uh, the, the, the focus
of the cantos once again,
the natural world,
the natural world and natural world,
which is one of sheer
chaos in the natural world,
which is one of violence.
And look at this image as the
Fleming between Vincent and Bruce.
You know,
the,
the Netherlands is describing literally
the Netherland calling called such
because there are lower,
the surface of the land is lower than
that of the water and they have to to
protect the, the, the
land from the violence of,
of the water and the floods.
So they build this diet around as the
Fleming's between Vincent and Bruce
fearing the flood Rushanian on them,
make the bulwark to drive back the sea.
And this,
the pageants do along the brand to
protect their towns and castles before the
kid. And Tana feels the heat this were
made of the same fashion except that the
builder, whether he was met them
neither, so high, no, so broad.
So the natural world that
can hardly be contained.
That's the idea.
The natural world that is always
going to overwhelm all efforts to,
uh, barriers trying to impede
its violence. By the way,
this is an image for those of you
who are readers of literature,
even beyond the Middle Ages.
Uh,
it's a famous image that
Machiavelli was use in, uh,
uh, in, in chapter 20, uh, five of the,
of the prints.
You remember when he talks about virtual
and fortunate and that the virtue of
human beings virtual the word
cat, actor at a tear, you know,
the virtual human beings
is to build, you know, uh,
shelters we talk to whenever
we expect the front,
but in the full knowledge that we
are never really going to succeed.
And yet we need the shelters
just in case we might succeed.
Virtual is always a little bit less
powerful than fortunate in his,
uh, in, in that world. It's a, it's an
image that in one of, uh, the history, uh,
plays Shakespeare also also uses,
I'm not saying that he
takes it from Dante said,
we don't know whether he actually
read down to or not already.
So this is the background
of this account already.
We had got to so far from the woods that
I should not have seen what it was if I
had turned backward when
we met a troop of souls.
We're coming alongside the bank and
each looked at us as men look at one
another.
And the new moon at dusk seems to create
this kind of a strange world of uh,
of the night worlds,
the night world and the packer,
the browse on us like an old
Taylor on the eye of his leader.
What an extraordinary,
extraordinary emerge that
will use something like this.
Not Quite the same image.
The paler, uh, when he's arriving,
when his to describe his own
vision of Paradise. It is a safe,
the most, the humbleness, the
humble, his experience in the city.
Uh, in Florence, you
know, the Artism, the,
the Taylor can only help him.
That was the only thing you can
think about as he's approaching.
There was sublime of experiences.
That's about it. These are 33,
and here this most are extraordinary.
A story has also the ring of familiarity
or that's really the image of a,
the way I think this image works,
the sense of a familiarity and that with
a familiar image of the tailor and the
tailor.
Also figure that picture measure
the Taylor is a figure of a,
of the Artism who in order to fit you
properly has really to have your measure.
Your idea of who you are.
Now I does. By that company,
I was recognized by one
who took by the help me,
but the hammock ride
her marvelous and die.
When he reached out his arm to me
fixed my eye on his vacant looks.
So the scorched features did not keep
my mind from recognizing him and bending
my face to his.
I answered are you here seven or eight?
Are you here sir?
Brunetto oh,
so this is the scene of the
recognition in in fair? No,
that's what you have seen.
So recognitions more
than first encounters.
It is as if literally recognizing means
knowing people that you thought you knew
and you knowing them. I knew all
the fingers that you thought you
knew something about red
of the recognition it means
also are giving a kind of
uh, understand and give me
a kind of the deal to them.
Recognizing in that sense
too. And He, oh my son,
but not explicitly.
If Retro Latini return back with the
little and let the train go on twice.
Brunetto refer to Dante's,
oh my son are the sorts
of acknowledging this,
this Felician acknowledging,
ah,
a kind of familiarity that goes beyond
even every, any form of discipleship.
And Dante will resist that,
that solicitation, that affectionate.
So recitation, that familiarity,
he will always refer to him as
they emerge of a father, but twice.
And then he says,
and I said to him with all my heart,
I beg of you and if you
wish me to sit with you,
I will if it pleases
him here with whom I go.
Meaning Virgil are mentioned as if
Dante now were concealing pro forma.
To be sure the shifted a loyalty
from one teacher to another and we're
considering it from Brunette within
again a cancer again, breathe, Oh son,
whoever this frog stops, et cetera. Um,
go under for a Chicago Matteis skirt,
which some critics have seen as a sign
of this is that the really Dante may have
known something about Prenatal
Athena that nobody else knew. Uh, uh,
later rejoined my band will,
who go morning that a turn or laws,
uh, look at the spatial
configuration of the scene. It's,
I think it's very significant.
The disciple is above the future is
below so that the disciple has to bow in
order to be able to speak to the teacher,
which would be a sign of his reverence
for the authority of the master.
But at the same time it indicates
that the hierarchy between them,
it's both the higher heat between them
really has completely altered from the
the days that they were or are in
the city, in the streets of Florence.
And then he tells the story up above them
and the bright light, I answered him,
not, I'm sorry, there's not descend
from the track, etc. And he says,
what chance of destiny Burritos as brings
the down here before their last day.
And who is this that shows the y chance
destiny Brunetto has no understanding of
the trajectory of Dante's
life and adventure.
And this is really the beginning of a
series of misunderstandings between the
teacher and the disciple tool.
Different value systems are being
deployed and there are going to be in
collusion with each other.
Brunetto speaks like a true humanist
and men who belonged to the CIS Aronian.
And who espouses this is Haronian ethics
for whom here the world is one indeed
of chance encounters, uh, uh, destiny, ah,
that takes us one way or the other and
there is nothing in the, the providential,
ah, about it. And Dante, uh,
a response by really giving a kind of
pithy summary of his experience in the
last few hours up above there
in the bright light. I answered,
I answered him before my age, who was at
the fool hill repeats in fair, no one,
I lost my way in a valley. He appeared
to me when I was returning to it.
And by this road he leads me home.
These are extraordinary rewards because
what home means for the politically
minded Florence centered and of existence
of Brunetto is not the idea of what
home means for Dante.
For Dante home is the place of the
soul and the place where the soul is,
uh,
at its most distended distension of the
solar cookers for Brunetto home can only
be the CTO forum.
One has a political frame of reference.
The other one has a theological frame
of reference and they two are colliding
with each other. Let's continue
and see how this is extraordinary.
And he said to me,
if you follow the star now again,
an extension of the language.
That metaphor picks up the metaphor of
chance of destiny, kind of astrology.
Follow your star, right? Uh,
the astrology of the desk in the destiny
of Dante Dao cannot fail the glorious
haven.
Another one another that is dramatizing
the radical ambiguity of words that seem
to be so bland,
like glorious,
glorious means to a humanist is not
what glorious means to a theological
reminded thing. You know, in
theology one things of nature,
grace and glory that
Dante Begins Paradise One,
the first word with which means
it's the glory of him. Gloria,
him who moves all things and glory from
Brunette to means the happy ending fame
and whatever the grill use heaven.
If I discern rightly in there for
life and then I'll die too soon,
seeing heaven so gracious to
the again, uh, uh, this is,
you know, glorious in
grace. Once again today,
I would have strengthened in thy work.
But a thankless and Malik malignant fork,
which came down with old
from fears or instill,
keeps something of the mountain and the
rock shall become for the world doing
that an enemy and with reason for among
the bitter Sobes, it's not natural.
The sweet thing should come to fruit.
Old Fame.
So from Brunette to his point of view,
the reference of all the crisis,
the spiritual crisis,
the laws of self of Dante
can only be political.
That Brunetto makes an incredible mistake
of believing that Dante's experience
is exactly the replica of his own.
He lost the city while he was,
by the way, Ron says, val,
the place, you know, where the,
where the Great Paladin of
Charlemagne or long, uh, was, was,
uh, it's a symbolic place.
He chooses was defeated.
And now this is exactly what he thinks.
It's happening also to, to Dante,
the pilgrim. Um, among the
bit of sobs, et Cetera,
old fame in the world calls and blind
people, avaricious and views and proud.
This is the,
the three sparks that have set the
hearts of the Florentines on fire.
And this pride envy,
average envy and pride are the fortune
holds the for such honor that one party
and the other shall be ravenous
against the, so then, uh,
the language that the
prophecy of Dante's exile,
the two parties [inaudible] Berlin's
will turn against them, et cetera.
And Dante answers, we're all my
prayers fulfilled. I answered him.
You had not yet been
banished from humanity.
For in my memory is fixed
and our goes to my heart,
the deer and kind paternal image
of you with many time in the world,
you taught me how man makes himself
immortal and how much I'm grateful for it.
My tongue where I live must needs to
declare that we should tell him my course.
I write and keep with another text for
comment by lady who will know if I reach
her.
Clearly an allusion to Beatrice,
though we will not be Beatrice who will
make the prophecy of Dante's exile.
But in this metrically,
uh,
connected Canto 1516 of Paradise
would be Dantes real grandfather.
So the distinction between this fictional
figure of a self proclaimed spiritual
father Brunetto and the the
heroic grandfather Cacciaguida,
uh, the, the, the antithesis is very, uh,
very clear and in the acknowledgement
that Dante gives of the acknowledgement
that Dante gives of, uh, um,
burritos teaching when
he says, um, for me,
my memory is fixed and
now goes to my heart,
the deer in kind paternal image of
you wear many time in the world.
You taught me how men
makes himself in mortal.
There's also a little bit of a critique,
a little bit of a distance that Dante
establishes between himself and Brunette.
For the true point.
The real authentic point of
Dante's experience is that
men does not make himself
and more, of course we're
involved. Withdrawal works.
Maybe there are many other forms of
achieving some degree of immortality,
but can make children to
become more to one hope,
at least a provisional
immortality, continuity. Uh,
but from dentist point of view,
the mortality that he's
seeking is not manmade,
can only be a question of
the salvation of his soul.
So in the very great acknowledgment
that form in which the disciple who just
love making these claims of indebtedness
to the teacher is also a sense of a
difference between them and
misunderstandings. Uh, and this, uh,
uh, we'll, uh, we'll,
we'll be in fact the trade
of this encounter to a
teacher who has been shaping
the disciple and the disciple
has been going his own way, uh,
who somehow things that
education means also, uh,
uh, is tantamount to an experience
of freedom. It's what we,
this is the way we began when,
uh, when I spoke about the dub,
the figures of doubleness in cantor 12.
And this is the theme that seems to be
going through even in the encounter with
Brunetto and let's see now exactly
then what is Brunette saw them.
Your way of understanding Burritos are
clearly linked to violence within the
world of violence. And so, um,
Dante wants to know about who the other
centers are and Burrito would comply and
sister all clerks and great and famous
scholars and he mentions them over the
father was one of the same sin pressure
if famous Grameen Arion, a Francesco,
the Corso who also is a, uh, by the way,
I think he's a lawyer and I started
as the craving such scarf, et cetera.
Now then he says,
I will say more,
but I cannot go farther talking with
the for I see there and new cloud rising
from the sand.
People are coming with whom
I must not be let my treasure
in which I get live,
be commended to the,
and I ask no more a true teacher,
I say,
who gives bibliography
at the end? Says, okay,
now you go and read my book or just read
everybody's book but I recommend to you
my treasurer come in,
which I get live to become mended today.
Then he turned about and seemed like one
of those who run for the green cloth in
the field at and Luda Cambridge,
an image of a race which is run in Verona.
And he seemed not the Roos are among them,
but the winner.
So he leaves with the illusion
that he is a precursor.
Is it where you understand what I mean?
That he's in a race.
He so far behind everybody else that
he seems not to be ahead of them.
He said,
really behind the one circle that's,
that's the emerge with which
Dante ends this encounter.
Brunetto recommends this treasure,
which was a French text that he wrote
this in an encyclopedia that he wrote in a
while in France and he wrote
it in French so much that, uh,
and it's so important this text,
it's one of the most important
encyclopedias in the vernacular.
Separate PD is being, I may have, I
even gave you, are I remember you,
I don't expect you to remember it,
but I gave you a definition of the divine
comedy is a poetic encyclopedia in the
sense that it tries to gather together
the broken pieces of knowledge of
experience.
And at the same time,
unlike the technical encyclopedias
such as the Britannica give you,
dramatize the presence of someone
who is being educated through them,
a process of education. Dante is the
one who is in the middle of learning.
So it's an encyclopedia with
a path about how to learn,
not the abstract one that
Brunetto had written, uh,
but it's written in French and it's, and,
and, and I stress this fact because Ah,
elsewhere one of his philosophical who
were refraction's Dante goes on thing
that we are all bound by natural
affection for our own language.
And because on account of that, there are
those who have, uh, put forth the, uh,
the interpretation that
Brunetto is here for the value,
violating the natural bonds
of affection that we have,
that human beings have to their own
natural language to their own, uh, uh,
mother language, let's call it
that. It could be, it could be. Uh,
but what I think this
is is, uh, a dramatizes,
an incredible self delusion
on the part of Brunette.
Here he is dead.
He is circling around under the reign
of fire and he thinks he still lived in
his own text.
He mistakes first of all,
the symbolic life that he has
within a text with reality.
That's a really, that's the first
confusion. That language of images,
the languages of seeming that is running,
that pervades this cantor
has to be understood in terms
of this confusion on the
part of the unit. Whether it
is more, there is more to it.
The mistake that Brunetto
makes is to believe that Dante,
Dante's whole life is a replica
of his own. Read my textbooks,
whatever it is that you have to know is
already available to you in my own book.
That is to say he faces the difference
between Dante and himself and Brunetto.
He refuses to see that
Dante's old life can have eh,
it's home development and it's home
destination, which at this national,
which she can not understand at all.
So that's the,
the end of Canto are 15 this,
this sodomy.
Then there's also confusion
between the real and the imaginary,
the way of drawing the real world
and to one of a fictional fictions.
And imaginations.
That is one scene before I stopped and
give you a chance to ask her a question.
Now we'll go into Canto
16. It's the end. Really.
We are reaching the end
of the intermediate area,
the moral or the ground of violence,
which to us of course, may,
I don't, I just presumed
that you may be surprised me.
We are cultures in full view of violence
really as the worst possible crime,
right? And violence in, in,
uh, uh, in all of its, uh,
its forms and, and uh,
it's, it's expressions,
the several psychological,
physical, uh, political and so on.
Uh, for dental, the real, the worst crimes
of the crimes of fraud. As you know,
this is our bad enough to to be sure,
but the, and that the show is about 20,
enter in,
canto with canto and cantor 17,
and he will see a strange failure.
Uh,
they are,
they have to go over a huge ravine.
There is no way that they can do
this. Uh, but then miraculously,
uh, uh, a figure, strange
figure, a monster, uh,
they are the edge of standing at the
edge of the pit. And a, a figure appears.
This is the figure of Jerry on that.
At the end of Canto 60,
let me read this image of
the figure of Jerry and, uh,
Dante will mount on Jerian and, uh, uh,
virtual will sit behind
him and they come in.
The descent takes place in three areas
of fraud. So this is the, the, the,
these are this, this is a sequence
of happenings in the cantor.
Um, and now let's, let's see
what Anthony says. It's, it's,
it's an experience of, uh, uh,
we would even call it wonder in her
ex experience of foremost the sublime,
uh, an infernal sublime. Amen.
This, I'm reading from 16,
they'll line one 30, uh,
around around one 30.
And following your main should always
closest lips as far as he can to the truth
that has the face of
ally. Oh, that's fraud.
Mixture of truth and deception,
truth and lies.
That's what literature seems
to do. Two though. No. Oh,
since without fault.
It brings him shame.
But here I cannot be silent.
And by the strains of this comedy is text,
this text called comedy.
And this historic moment of an
experience of descent comedy also, uh,
captures this, uh, this, this rhetoric
of descent, of lowering oneself.
I not just an aesthetic experience.
I swear to the reader.
Another,
the second address to the reader,
and you may remember that
we saw one in Canto or nine,
and I tried to explain it to you as the
address to the reader as part of the
strategy of authority on the
part of Dante in the measuring,
which I need readers
and I may have readers.
Then I'm constantly rooted into an author.
You understand that that kind of strategic
moves or I swear to the reader that I
saw coming swimming up
to that gross murky air,
a figure,
amazing to the stout as heart.
Even as he returns who goes down sometime
to lose the anchor that is called to
the reef or something else.
He didn't see stretching
upward and drawing in his feet.
This is the story.
This is the approach of Jerry on what
I want to point out is a number of
metaphors here.
This is an aerial journey.
Jerian is flapping his wings
and going through the murky air.
Dante describes it as if it were a
journey by see the metaphor he uses his
swimming.
I go,
I saw come swimming up through the grass
grows and murky and by the way when
Dante's to describe the
story of a mythic sailor,
mythic mariner Ulysses whom we are
going to encounter hopefully next week.
I think it's going to be next
week in a or next time the,
he describes this journey by CEO of
Ulysses as if it were a journey by air and
he does this because for Dante it
doesn't matter how you are traveling,
if you fly or you go by water,
it doesn't matter because all journeys
are journeys to the same destination.
All journalists are really
journeys to the absolute.
He Agera one Samsung to come
to play a ministerial function.
He's going to minister to serve Dante and
his guide and at the same time that it
says here to there is some
kind of plan here to this.
I'm kind of something of the
absolute that I have to see.
So that's the first image.
The second image is this idea of um,
uh, the, the, uh, which will
be described really later.
The rotatory movement of
Jerian through the air.
And I have been described as the circle,
the spiral, that movement in the spiral,
the spiral motion of a all or,
or movement in, in, in
fandom. And the third,
this is this idea of the
swearing by dontre's own text.
That text is given now the
value of a sacred object,
something that has, um,
something one can swear by.
If we began with a violation
of the hernia, then canto 13.
Now in Canto 16,
tell poses to the AENEID
and look to every places.
Therefore the new text for us.
It's this common it,
let me stop here and uh,
let me see that we have a
few minutes for questions,
which I will welcome and tried
to answer about five, 10 minutes.
Yeah, I have a quick thing I want
to clear up. Um, cancer, uh, 13, uh,
at the end when you did let me not
being the artist talking about Augustus,
he's referring to Frederick
said the Gusto. Yes. Make sure.
Yeah. The, uh, it's,
it's what we call a
typological use of the emperor.
The emperor has to be,
it's Augustus or Caesar.
These are the two terms used
for the emperor. So it's a type,
it's the kind of abstract type
or the czar or the Kaiser,
the bowl versions of the Caesar
a myth, you know, I mean,
in more than languages. So, uh,
yeah, that's, it starts this. Yes.
Talk about those people who are guilty.
That gets me off
guilty and bulbous shows
over rationality.
They're in the second circle.
The sodomites are either the seventh,
the difference there because look,
we're serious. Violation of natural law,
intellectual choice of near a park.
Two engage in behavior,
both intellect,
which is much more serious then the
incompetence of the people in the second
circle.
The question is, uh, um,
uh, mental, uh, have me,
uh, think about the relationship between
the centers of lust and the centers of
sodomy. Uh, and uh,
at the premise of the question
is that in the centers of lost,
we have a sinners who invert the
order of reason and pleasure.
Uh,
what has mishandled the question then
is why are the centers of sodomy,
uh, placed in Eh, for
the law down in Hell?
And if this is because there's a
question of, uh, intellectual choice,
uh, this has been, uh, uh, at
my answer is the following, uh,
that the, uh, no,
there's no indication in this
cantos in Canto 15 that uh,
the city here, that there is some,
uh, that intellectual perversions.
But you are right.
Your question is well taken that all
clinics in the sense of a clinics meaning
not just where are we today thing as man
of the cloth but meaning intellectuals,
pressure, uh, are cool shoes. Uh, who is,
who is also mentioned their
famous Seta, uh, of the laws, uh,
then Burrito Latino himself.
Uh,
the scene here is a sin of uh,
violence.
Uh, justice. We had the
idea that education,
the educators in Canto 12, uh,
those who are, who could, who,
who, uh, what could, could pervert
the very process of teaching.
And just as in canto 13,
we had a stoic pf the Levenia is really
a story or a story called now reflects
that suicide is not a virtual and
the virtuous choice. But this, uh,
this has sinners who have veal.
The tool,
whether this anger to the,
and the have yield,
the tool,
the impulses of violence within them.
Dante I think is condemning sodomy.
Cause I think this is also part of the
question you're asking may not be the
central part,
but because it is whatever there has been
violence connected to their activity,
this is the why would he placed them
in, uh, in the circle of violence?
Unlike for instance, what
happens to, uh, we the,
when it said limb cut in Canto
26 or Caesar, by the way,
there's also an illusion to
Caesar in Canto 26 or purgatory.
So there's a difference there.
It teacher who uses violence.
So that's the link between teaching
a violence in Canto 12, uh,
the man of a reason,
the story believer in the logos.
Uh, and, and, and, and, and, and
the old rule of rationality, uh,
are exasperates a principal and believes
that he can be both judge and a and
victim at sec executioner and the executed
one and now in Canto 15 is this idea
of, uh, uh, and then the, the,
the way in which violence
has taken over and, uh,
and obfuscated the older of rationality.
I don't see the element of choice in that.
Yes.
Can you maybe discuss how Dante
differentiates various representations of
suicides since Lucretia is in limbo,
died on,
circled the last fall,
and then we have [inaudible] who is in
the actual circle of suicide and how is
it that he makes the distinction
between where they fall?
It's impossible to differentiate within
different forms of suicide since Dante.
And that's exactly right.
Exactly true. Done.
Do we have Lucretia in limbo?
We have dido in Canto to,
among the, the last, last fall,
souls will have Cato in purgatory,
et cetera.
And why here in Canto Canto 13,
suicides are punished.
Is there some kind of rationale
that we can see behind the various,
that's a question.
The various forms of suicide.
The answer that I would
give is the following. Um,
Dante know so well that they are the
phenomenology of acts or various acts is
vast and cannot quite be ever be brought
to one common element so much that the
beginning of Canto 14,
if you turn to canto 14,
Dante's going through the hot
sands because it's, it's, it's,
it's the burning sands of,
of her and he remembered,
he recalls there.
This must be exactly the burning
sands of the Libyan desert,
that Keto Cross, which is a way of
saying, you know, don't be surprised.
I think if you're going to
encounter Cato further down,
I know that you expect them to be here.
So the question is how does Dante
go on determining the particular,
the value of particular act
when we sin?
This may be a little bit, um, I
have to be very clear about this.
Okay, what did we say? We usually
can say, well, how can it be,
I'm going to give you a kind of,
I'm going to take a little bit of a
distance from this whole question.
It's easy to say,
how can Dante be so mmm
ruthless that someone,
for all we know him have been a good
human being and then the committed one
crime and they are in
hell forever for eternity.
That on the face of it would seem to be,
uh,
a reasonable query. You know,
it was sort of indirect,
too bleak way of asking for it,
a little bit more tolerance
and benevolence from this
men who claims to be the
supreme judge of all human beings have,
uh,
have been perpetrating. The
fact is the, whenever we sin,
Oh sins had involved,
we think that it's only one
that old sins had involved.
And Dante highlights one specific
aspect in the case of Dido.
Her is more important than in the sense
of more decisive and determines the
character of that figure.
Then the suicide,
their suicide is seen as
an extension of her loss.
In the case of Lucretia put her in limbo.
That is a wing which Dante really wants
to make that clear distinction and leave
an Antigo stadium.
The stadium moment that look,
creatures virtuals seem to
have been limited as they are.
She's not saved in any way,
but there is a kind of exemplary
virtual that that allows him to sort of
remember but not punish her for a crime,
which is really to be understood as
a consequence of an excessive way of
understanding virtual.
You see what I'm saying?
In the case of Cato and we are going to
see that he sees the sacrifice of self
for freedom. That's really the, the, the,
the great understanding.
Keto dies for the sake
of freedom and the whole,
the Canto purgatory is a riff.
The cantor one of authority is a
reflection on the question of freedom,
Roman freedom.
And by the way,
the biblical Jewish understanding
of freedom of to, you know,
I'm preparing you for that Canto.
So maybe I'll save myself the trouble
of repeating these things when we get
there. Dante, we'll talk about, uh, uh,
Roman freedom through Keto in
the military. After, uh, uh,
the troop of angels will arrive and
they sing one song which is in exit to
Israel.
The Egypt wishes is to say the
Jewish are this famous psalm one 13,
a psalm of David.
When David is reflecting
about the epic of Exodus,
the lyrical,
lyrical reflection I party idea that
caring from Egypt on the way to to
Jerusalem was,
which only some got two friends Moses
never did is really a quest for freedom.
So they are two ideas of free,
not political or civil freedom and
the theological idea of freedom.
And that's really the key to understanding
the Cato and understanding the way
Dante connects these two traditions,
the Roman and the Jewish traditions.
Other questions?
We have one minute and the tape
probably last about 45 seconds.
So we get the question or answer
questions.
Seems like you're saying here that
Dante is almost finding a kind of sand
when virtue is taken into your next
steps. Yes. You can go too far.
You can be too obsessed
with a certain yes.
Misdirection of virtue.
Yes. It's not a question,
but it was, I said yes, yes.
And I would agree. The port, the,
the, the reflection is, it seems,
I don't like that it seems
that I'm saying, but I'm
saying that actually, that,
um, uh, that, that, uh,
uh, in Dante, Dante,
uh,
views the access of virtual
also are as part of something,
part of the sin is sin. And I
would agree with agree. Yes.
Okay. Thank you. We'll see you next time.